wonderful that proved Muhammad's assalam
if we take the high D for six or nine no
not that he waited before he because he
married at 6:00 and then he to me so for
that for that waiting period to take
place give me the evidence if you don't
give me the evidence then I'm gonna have
to apologize to the camera because you
know I'm gonna say to you my friend yeah
sorry what's your name
okay we have your name is yeah I'm gonna
say something such a hadith does much
literature on you so he said that he
does for playful I'm gonna say to you
right now I'm gonna humiliate you right
now yeah you're humiliated already you
know why because you've mentioned
something that does not exist in the
literature I'm putting my own reputation
on the line right now by saying that
such a thing does not exist in even one
hadith in any of the 42 main books of
hadith 42 not even those two 642 books
it doesn't exist is my slave even more
doesn't even there's not even an element
of it if you can find it and read it
with the son of the saya then you to
shut me up
but if you can't you're gonna have to
apologize to the camera now I've well
seen your face and you're gonna be
humiliated in front of at least 30 or 40
thousand people whatever your name is
everyone sees your face since you're the
one who tried to come to me in speaker's
corner and say that my prophet had four
plates over wash at such an age now
you're gonna be better on the way this
is the thing look so you you are very
dignified in your approach and you are
coming humbling
keep yourself look we can't ask you as
my father where's the father
Burnaby Ohio I've insisted where's the
same of ah ha ha ha oh look at you
you're I'm really exited for my presence
that's right that's right get all of
your people no seriously because you
come in and saying that my profit
he said no [__] the older woman over
the gala signage now I've caught you
like the boy that you are you're
finished you are finished you're
finished in my presence just like David
wills finish sorry man you're finished
you come you tried your best
who's next
he came to me saying that the Prophet
Muhammad Rasul and Mo Farah which means
no it means he them friction like
touching the legs over yeah yeah no I I
want to know I want to know I've refuted
it quite convincingly are you gonna
apologize in front of the camera for of
the thousands of people are watching boy
oh yeah I keep keep looking keep looking
it's not there brother
it's not that you know what else is not
there Trinity in your Bible that's what
you should be looking